[Musique]
il a joué un rôle dans la constitution
de deux institutions qui sont très
importantes
d'abord c'est la milice qui a été créée
en 1992 et qui était au départ une aile
de jeunesse du parti de l'ancien parti
unique du 2g vénale habyarimana le mrnd
et saisines et la moue et ont commis
beaucoup de violence contre les tutsis
et contre les opposants hutus au régime
habyarimana avant le génocide et pendant
le génocide ce sont des acteurs centraux
des massacres l'ags seconde institution
la radio télévision libre des mille
collines qui a été créée sous l'égide de
félicien kabuga en tout cas avec ses
financements en partie en avril 1993 et
qui a commencé à émettre en juillet de
la même année et la rtlm la radio
télévision libre des mille collines a
incité publiquement sur ses ondes a
assassiné un certain nombre de réfugiés
tutsis donc il est vraiment au coeur de
la constitution de cette radio qui
vraiment à accompagner la montée au
génocide puis à accompagner aussi la
commission des massacres entre avril et
juillet 1994
donc selon nous est vraiment lié à
deux instructions très importante du
génocide et ruthy
il faut savoir que son nous apparaît
également dans le rapport de human
rights watch et la fédération et ancien
les droits de l'homme pour avoir en 1993
et 1994
importé des centaines de tonnes de
machettes donc qui ont été ensuite
distribués notamment aux miliciens de la
wii mais aussi à la population dans le
cadre de ce qui était appelé à l'époque
l'auto défense civile à l'armement du du
peuple civile contribue donc à à la
guerre comme une applet contre les
tutsis
[Musique]
ce génocide a été préparé en amont et
s'ils n'avaient pas été préparés aussi
minutieusement mais il n'aurait jamais
été aussi efficace je rappelle qu'entre
le 7 avril 1994 et la mi juillet de la
même année près d'un million de
personnes ont été littéralement 8 est
assassiné
vous vous rendez compte sur un laps de
temps aussi bref un nombre de victimes
aussi important eh bien ça ne
s'improvise pas un puisque c'est un
décès du génocide le plus le plus rapide
de l'histoire du 20e siècle
[Musique]
il a d'abord trouvé refuge en suisse où
il avait été je dirais héberger le
parpaing de ses gendres
me fabien singaye et
[Musique]
une sorte de d'espions au service du
pouvoir habyarimana et puis il a été
expulsé et je peux dire que là je dirais
que c'est là la faute originelle dans
cette affaire kabuga parce que à partir
de là
kabuga a disparu parce que c'est
[Musique]
les etats-unis utiliseront les
ressources à leur disposition pour aider
à l'arrestation de ces fugitifs
c'est pour mettre fin une fois pour
toutes à cette entreprise criminelle
la récompense pouvant aller jusqu'à 5
millions de dollars montre cette
détermination
on aurait pu penser que ça puisse
provoquer des réactions plus rapide
parce que le symbole de l'art c'est
quand même une somme importante
par contre je ne sais pas ce qu'il en
est advenu je ne sais pas si kabuga
aurait été vendu par un des siens pour
cette somme de 5 millions $ probablement
nous ne saurons nous jamais
en allemagne en 2007 se trouvait pour
des soins je crois que chez son autre
jambe
augustine ghellab a de quoi ré qui lui
même avait échappé à la police française
quelque temps plus tôt et lorsque la
police allemande où les polices qui
étaient chargés d'arrêter là bas tu peux
aller sont venus le chercher
on vient de kabuga qui dirait par chance
pour lui a échappé des policiers ne
l'ont pas reconnu
on s'est rendu compte que on avait des
enfants qui étaient présentes sur le
territoire national et en faisant des
recherches un peu plus précise sur
asnières on a pu s'apercevoir qu'il
avait location d'un appartement qui
était louée par un des enfants
samedi ça a été je dirais le coup de
tonnerre pour moi j'ai parlé d'une bombe
dans le milieu judiciaire
l'arrestation de kabuga qu'on dit se
trouver en france depuis même plusieurs
années
c'est ça qui est le plus extraordinaire
comment at il pu se cacher si longtemps
sans que personne n'en sache rien quels
sont les complicités dont il a bénéficié
bien sûr un de ses fils l'a aidé
l'aurait aidé à s'installer à asnières
mais est ce que est ce que ça suffit
pour entrer sur le territoire français
de quel passeport
il a quel passeport il a utilisé on sait
que il était en possession de plusieurs
passeports de faux passeports par
exemple lorsqu'il était en allemagne en
suisse
il avait un faux passeport tanzanien
donc moi je compte beaucoup sur cet
événement capital de l'arrestation de
kabuga d'abord d'une part je dirais un
petit peu pour mettre un coup de pied
dans la fourmilière du tout les
génocidaires qui se cachent encore
actuellement en france et qui
certainement vont se faire discrète mais
je compte aussi comme je voulais dire
sur le réveil du dossier d'agathe
habyarimana
et puis j'espère que l'interrogatoire
auquel il va être soumis va nous aider à
faire un peu la lumière sur ce qu'a été
la fin de cette cavale et surtout
son séjour en france